[Vsauce 2]
This house in Germany was built
upside down,
including every single room
and all of the furniture,
and it's referred to
as "The World Stands on its Head."
What the FAK?
The Facts and Knowledge
on weird houses.
This upside-down house
located in Poland
was created by Daniel Czapiewski.
The house was meant to be
a profound statement
about the Communist Era
and the state of the world.
Normally built in three weeks,
this house took 114 days,
because the workers were so disoriented
by the strange angles of the walls,
and many tourists complain
of seasickness and dizziness
after only a few minutes
of being inside.
The Ensculptic was built
by Winslow Wedin in Minnesota
and was constructed almost entirely
out of foam.
The 4,000-square foot,
two bedroom, three bathroom house
has plenty of amenities,
including a fireplace, garage, and deck,
but when it was for sale,
the vaulted ceiling,
rounded corners, and curved walls
were the primary selling point.
The Futuro House was designed
by Matti Suuronen,
and it looks like a flying saucer.
Fewer than 100 were built
in the 60s and 70s,
and the distinctive shape
makes them popular among collectors.
Composed of polyester,
plastic, and fiberglass,
it was designed as a ski cabin
that would be quick to heat
and easy to construct
in rough terrain.
But the house was taken
off the market in the mid-'70s,
when high gas prices made
the manufacture of plastic extremely expensive.
It's estimated that around 50
of the original Futuro homes are still around.
The Guitar House is located
in Fayetteville, Georgia,
and was built
by country-Western singer Elvis Carden.
The 3,800-square foot,
guitar-shaped home
took 16 years to build.
The exterior walls had
the perfect curves of a Gibson.
It has aluminum cables
across the length for strings,
and upon completion,
Carden released an album
called Living in an Old Guitar.
The Dog Bark Park Inn is
a bed and breakfast
inside the world's largest beagle.
Located in Idaho, it was built
by husband and wife owners
Dennis Sullivan and Frances Conklin.
Guests enter the body of the beagle
through a private second-story deck,
and the head of the dog is a loft
with a cozy alcove in the muzzle.
The dog bed and breakfast
is nicknamed Sweet Willy,
and the 12-foot-tall smaller beagle
is named Toby.
Oh, and the 11-foot fire hydrant nearby
contains a public restroom for humans.
Joanne Ussary bought a 727
and spent $24,000 dollars
on renovations, converting it
into her dream home.
There are three bedrooms,
a living room, and a modern kitchen.
There's a jacuzzi in the cockpit,
and Joanne's bedroom is in first class.
She says next time she wants
a Boeing 747,
because those have an upstairs,
and she wants to go upstairs to go to bed.
And there's also a guy
named Bruce Campbell in Oregon
who renovated his own Boeing 727
into a home,
but his cost
around $200,000 dollars.
In Helen, Pennsylvania,
there's a 48-foot long,
25-foot tall shoe house.
The shoe house was completed
in 1949
by shoe store owner Colonel Haines
for advertising purposes.
Haines walked up to an architect,
handed him an old work boot,
and said, "Build me a house
like this."
So located on Shoe House Road,
it has a shoe mailbox
and a boot-decorated fence
surrounding the yard.
The dog house is shaped like a boot,
and every window in the shoe house
is decorated
with a stained glass shoe.
The front door has a stained glass portrait
of the Colonel holding shoes,
and the current owners sell "Heel-basi"
and "Toe-Dogs" out of a snack bar in the heel.
Walking House is
a modular dwelling system
that enables people to live
a peaceful, nomadic life,
moving slowly with minimal impact
on the environment.
It collects energy using solar cells
and small windmills.
There's a system
for collecting rainwater
and a system
for solar-heated hot water.
Walking House is not dependent
on roads,
but actually moves
on many different kinds of terrain
at a slow pace similar
to that of a walking human.
For 33 years, Robert Bruno designed
and built his Steel House
on the edge of a canyon.
Located in Lubbock, Texas,
all of the walls in the home
are either welded metal
or original glass creations,
all designed to optimize the light
and the visual experience.
The late mayor
of Suwon, South Korea, Sim Jae-Duck,
built his loo-shaped,
two-story home
to mark the 2007 inaugural meeting
of the World Toilet Association.
Jae-Duck, reportedly born
in a restroom,
made it his life's work
to advocate for clean and working sanitation
for more than two billion people
living without toilets worldwide.
The 4,520-square foot
steel, concrete and glass structure
set Mayor Toilet back $1.1 million dollars.
It features
a showcase glass-walled bathroom
at its center, but those concerned
with privacy
can turn the walls opaque
at the touch of a button.
It features a rooftop balcony
that's accessible
by a toilet drain staircase,
and it's referred to
as Mr. Toilet House.
Located in Austria,
the Auto Residence looks
like a futuristic Volkswagen Bug.
Designed by Markus Voglereiter,
it has two separate living spaces
that are connected
by metal staircases,
and there are numerous windows
throughout the house,
making the entire car home
bright and sunny.
John Milkovisch loved beer
a lot, so he covered his house
with aluminum siding
made entirely of flattened beer cans.
Over 18 years, he attached
around 50,000 beer cans.
When asked why, he said,
"I guess I thought it was a good idea,
and it's easier than painting."
The house and landscape are adorned
with many different types of beer
that John drank mostly himself.
He even used the pull tabs
and tops and bottoms
to make curtains
for his Beer Can house.
I'm going to leave you
with this weird house—
who designed it,
and what was it called?
Before we go,
here's last video's winner.
Be sure to subscribe
for more Vsauce 2,
and as always,
thanks for watching.
[Vsauce 2]